aus den nordstream Pipelines wird in
diesen Stunden regelrecht Schweizer Käse
denn der pipeline-krimi er geht weiter
nach mehreren Explosionen in der Ostsee
nach drei Löchern jetzt also ein viertes
Lack an beiden Gaspipelines nordstream 1
und 2 jetzt ist also ganz klar es gibt
ein viertes Leck in der Ostsee Röhre
Schwedens küstenwarrates entdeckt etwa
200 Meter lang damit gibt es nun zwei
Lex auf schwedischen und zwei auf
dänischen Gebiet und das heißt nun auch
es kann nur Sabotage gewesen sein der
Verdacht liegt bei Russland die weisen
alle Vorwürfe zurück kündigen eigene
Ermittlungen an und wir schalten jetzt
zu unserem Reporter Sebastian Prengel er
ist auf der dänischen Insel Bornholm die
Gaspipeline führt hier direkt an der
Küste vorbei und keine andere Insel ist
so unmittelbar von dieser Attacke
betroffen Sebastian ein viertes Gasleck
was kannst du uns vor Ort dazu sagen
ja ja bisher gerade eben schon gesagt
die schwedische Küstenwache hat das
bestätigt es gibt ein viertes lag also
zwei auf schwedischen Küstengebiet zwei
auf dänische und damit ist jetzt auch
wirklich klar dass es sich um Sabotage
handelt es gab ja auch diese Theorie das
möglicherweise Schiffe mit einem Anker
die Schäden verursacht haben also wer
jetzt noch daran glaubt dem ist wirklich
nicht mehr zu helfen das hier ist ein
klarer Sabotageakt das sollte jetzt
wirklich jedem klar sein knapp 40.000
Menschen Leben aufbauen wollen wie groß
ist jetzt die Angst bei dir auf der
Insel
ja man ist hier natürlich sehr
verunsichert und zwar zu Recht also das
ist zwar im internationalen Gewässern
passiert aber dennoch hier direkt vor
der Haustür und das macht den Menschen
Angst und viele Leute haben uns hier
natürlich erzählt dass sie natürlich
merken dass sie Gefahren näher kommt und
das ist im Prinzip ja auch Putins Taktik
er will dass die Leute Angst haben er
will hier für dich Stabilisierung sorgen
und genau das gelingt ihm auch die
Menschen die merken dass die haben Angst
und man muss allerdings auch sagen es
wird auch viel für das Sicherheitsgefühl
getan es sind Kriegsschiffe hier in der
Ostsee unterwegs und auf der Insel sind
auch zwei F16 Kampfjets stationiert die
jederzeit einsatzbereit sind herzlichen
Dank Sebastian Prengel für die aktuellen
Informationen live von der dänischen
Insel Bornholm
und das klingt tatsächlich wie aus einem
Agenten Thriller es ist aber Realität
drei Explosionen an den beiden
Gaspipelines nordstream 1 und 2
mittlerweile vier Löcher die Welt
geschockt seit Montag es war ein
Sabotageakt sagen Experten aber wer
steckt wirklich dahinter
wer ist schuld diese Frage steht
weiterhin im Raum und wird mit Hochdruck
geheimdienstlich untersucht gab es ein
gezielten Anschlag auf die
gasinfrastruktur in Europa und wer
profitiert davon der Vorsitzende der
politischen militärischen Gesellschaft
und ehemaliger oberstreift Thiele hat da
eine Vermutung ich bin im Augenblick
bezüglich Russland etwas skeptisch weil
die Russen ja indem sie diese beiden
Pipeline sprengen eigene Optionen
verlieren deswegen da stehen zu bleiben
macht aus russischer Sicht keine keinen
Sinn wenn das allerdings eine Art
falsche flaggen-operation sein sollte
mit der sie erst die eigenen kaputt
machen und dann weitere kaputt machen
nehme ich zum Beispiel norwegische oder
die gerade in Polen eröffnete Pipeline
dann macht das wieder so eine Art
täuschungssinn weil man den anderen
sagen kann naja wir sind bekämpft worden
die anderen sind bekämpft worden wir
waren es nicht also das ist jetzt eine
sehr heikle Situation die Suche nach dem
einsprenger geht weiter viele könnten es
gewesen sein doch die Spuren werden
eindeutiger
die Situation also mehr als beunruhigend
was wenn das jetzt noch nicht alles war
wenn nach dem Angriff auf die
ostsee-pipelines noch weitere Anschläge
folgen wenn es wieder unsere kritische
Infrastruktur trifft beim BMD fügt man
gerade alle Hinweise zusammen das
Bundesinnenministerium erklärt zur
Sicherung der Infrastruktur in
Deutschland die Maßnahmen würden an die
Lage angepasst und BILD erfuhr die
Bundespolizei hat in Nord- und Ostsee
alles zu Wasser gelassen was schwimmen
kann und in der Bundesregierung spricht
man wohl nach den Anschlägen von
gewachsener Sorge dazu gehört auch die
cybersicherheit Unternehmen
Organisationen und Behörden sie alle
sollen ihre it-sicherheitsmaßnahmen noch
einmal überprüfen und schon im August
hatte bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
vor Attacken auf Gast Terminals gewarnt
jetzt waren sie dass wir uns auf
Szenarien einstellen müssen die bis vor
kurzem kaum denkbar waren
[Musik]